live hey everybody welcome to stream
Coco yeah yet no one else is clapping
its I'm the only best king Thank You
Beth for clapping welcome everybody
happy holidays
it's the end of the year we're all very
excited to wrap things up and skedaddle
on to holiday break before we do we're
super excited because you know this week
we are partnering with Google Play to
bring you some of the best mobile games
of 2017 we're super excited because
we've never done any mobile gaming we've
never done it on streem coco we've never
done an i clueless gamer me and my
personal life I've never done it I'm not
a big mobile gamer I frankly thought
they were stupid and I hated them but
the last two weeks I've been playing a
bunch and I gotta say man
they are super fun and addicting so you
know every year Google play's editorial
team rounds up their their picks their
favorite picks of the year and so I have
then taken those rounded up picks and
picked some of my favorites that I can't
stop playing and if I can't stop and
I'll tell this story later
I literally have taken these games out
to restaurants and played them the
entire time while I've been eating
dinner definitely alone of course Who am
I of course alone so these are super fun
we're gonna go through a bunch this hour
and thank you all for joining us Zuma
get chicken that's me yeah it says don't
die Aaron I am probably going to die
quite a bit in all these mobile games
just because they're mobile games
doesn't mean I'm any better at them yeah
you know also quick before we get
started this is our holiday gift this
year look this jacket look at this Conan
jacket we got and like there's a hood
involved can I do this can i mr. robot
yeah there we go perfect so uh thanks
Kanzi thanks so much thanks boss it's a
great and there's a zipper right here to
look at the zipper for if you want to
put some mobile phone Wow well done well
done all right
um I can let's start mobile gaming Beth
give me some room to roll the game
please get Lord I'd like to have my
elbows out when
and I think you should too okay so we're
gonna be going through a bunch of games
but I'm gonna say right now as we all
know I'm a child and when I saw a Google
place list the one that stuck out to me
of course
was this very first one it's called
balls that's right but balls with a Z
because it's cool hey Aseema one two
three four what's up auntie mutts how's
it going for all Abdulla
you guys I'm sorry don't get a jacket
because you don't work on Conan but you
can get these great mobile games on the
Google Play Store look at how I see what
I did there okay so this game's called
balls
now here's the thing what I love about
mobile games is they run the gamut from
the very simple to the very complex I
won't get to some of those later but I
love the idea I don't know who created
balls but hats off to you guys and gals
because it's a very simple concept it's
kind of like what's that arachnoid with
that old game what's the one I'm
thinking of with the thing underneath
breakout right that this is the
International sign for breakout if you
sit Conan three times he'll up here
maybe he will maybe you should say Conan
three times that yes so and again it's a
very simple it's a very simple game but
it's super addictive so the idea here is
every every one of these numbers you
have these are the amount of number
these are the amount of hits it takes
the amount of balls it takes to get rid
of these blocks so we're in sorceries
the best mobile game hands-down our
Monument Valley whoo I love it are you
guys Mol let's see your favorite mobile
games in the chat everybody will the
stream witness Conan's beautiful face I
don't know
stay tuned if you keep saying Conan's
he's kind of like beetlejuice if you
keep saying his name maybe he'll show up
that's right yes and I I'm not gonna lie
guys part of the reason why I chose this
game is so I could just say balls over
and over also I will say one thing that
kind of surprised me about starting to
play mobile games now you see I just
died immediately is they take way more
concentration way more concentration
than other video games like that
I find myself like hunched over my
mobile device playing these things and
getting really upset when I'm not good
so apologies in advance because I take
kami seriously y'all also balls first of
all I would also like to say my best
record 55 up top I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to get to this in this
stream 55 because I was in the ball zone
you know I was zone in with balls
candy crush in hearthstone that's great
awesome centipede dune is awesome yeah I
love it
all good stuff yes exactly and I also I
will say I hope everybody and the chat
recognizes what a softball I gave you by
playing balls first I just want to want
that to be known the idea here is you
hit the blocks that that gives you an
extra ball or extra balls I'm not sure
if it's like a plural thing but it
actually does this highlights how bad I
am at geometry and math so I do feel a
little bad every there we go but if I
can get in this stream if I could get
enough balls going on it's magical it's
magical balls guys I'm not gonna do well
this is gonna be embarrassing also when
I was playing I also say this I'm in a
room full of people right now and it's a
little nerve-racking to play balls in
front of a bunch of people because alone
in my apartment playing balls I was
doing really great and I was really
balling it up but I feel like now this
isn't gonna go as well because I'm
playing balls in public uh do I use
middle school geometry was the last time
I took geometry I mean it's been I'm
like 98 99 years old I don't want to
give my true age but it's around 96
I haven't taken geometry in a good 40
years and I was terrible at it Oh see
this it's just a very it's just a very
sad situation all right we got a lot of
games to get through I'm gonna try two
more quick balls sessions there's no way
to
make this dirty yeah I don't know if we
can get a balls counter going on I think
I probably said it about 15 times I will
say for those of you who like balls the
game I gotta say that what you want to
do is the key to this game I found is do
you want to get up above you want to get
you know you want to get your balls up
above the whole thing so then it can
rain down the balls can rain down on the
numbers because you want to get some
good bounces which I'm not doing
properly there is actually serious
strategy in this game I know I'm joking
because the name is something that's
hilarious but you can't name her game
balls and not expect me to see in a
perfect world I would get up in there
alright here we go watch this guy's
oh that was depressing okay watch this
though there we go there we go see this
is what I'm talking about this is the
beauty of balls when you get out see
look at that
oh yes Oh perfect oh that tennis turned
me down though I think I'm gonna get
nailed by this there's a lot of it's
deceptive this game is deceptively
difficult okay see we're doing okay
we're doing okay we're at nine Oh see
now this is now you're starting to get
some good balls action if I can get that
15 oh so you just got to get to a point
where you can get your balls really up
there there we go perfect nailed it
right I got to take care of this 22 here
for a second sorry everybody
now see you would think I think I want
it to go there we go there we go there
we go see here we go here we go okay
gotta get that 13 dammit
now I've always loved I'm playing a
tablet now I was playing when I was
practicing on my phone and I've always
loved giant screen phones because I have
a huge head and a big face and I you
know I don't wanna you know it's not
like I don't want to cuz you
Lander Scituate oh shoot oh shoot I want
a Zoolander situation where I'm talking
on the phone like this and I gotta say
for mobile gaming this big screen man is
the way to go oh look at that
Oh see this is what we're talking about
but I don't think I've got a random ball
okay okay this is good
what if I could just get rid of these
I'm dead I'm dead
that's it I'm dead all right guys I'm
never gonna I'm never gonna get I'm
never gonna get to where I want to be
with balls but it's a great game again
very fun very simple and also I will say
the thing I love about mobile games is
you know Google Play has a bunch of has
a bunch of different kinds of games and
balls was in the category of the most
popular you can see why
now we're gonna play battle Bay which is
in one of the categories called most
competitive and we're going from what I
thought mobile games were when you think
of mobile games you think of a very
simple very simple game you think of you
know just you know arachnoid or whatever
but then I opened a game like battle bay
and this thing is badass you're playing
against other people you're on a giant
board you've got different weapons
it's pretty dope and you actually use
the tablet or your mobile device like a
controller which is cool and something I
had never done before which is pretty
great I will say I'm a little
disappointed because when I first heard
of the game battle Bay I thought I was
gonna be battling Michael Bay and it
turns out that battle Bay is actually
location it's like a bay like a pool of
water so it's a little let down but you
know it's still great it's still great
Slayer Darth Beth is here Beth you want
to put your hand in that's in the window
there she is
but I have I'm having her sit over there
she's in the chat you could say hi to
Beth but I I get kind of I like to move
I like to have I throw off a lot of heat
when I'm mobile gaming as Beth can
attest to Beth's house my heat
production it's hot it's a lot there's a
lot of heat being thrown over here
that's right
liquid snake I love the emoticon or
emoji con or whatever it's called okay
so we're gonna do a little battling and
we actually can play against real people
so this is our team all right
now I've talked a big game I actually
have two alright so here we go so on the
left there this is how and again I've
never really done this with a mobile
game before this is how they do these
are my weapons I can choose here I got
the old mortar got the torpedo which by
the way is total BS torpedo doesn't work
for me let's get going gents and it's
very I'm not exactly sure how realistic
this game is but I feel like the fluid
dynamics are pretty oh man see here we
go we gotta look around here you just
gotta take a take time lining up your
shot oh yeah come on dude
I don't know if I've lost a match in
this game but now that I'm playing in
public I feel like I'm gonna lose a lot
of matches yeah let's go bro
shite sorry hey will George what's up I
will say it is really they're capturing
something it's really hard to both play
Oh dudes I might
he's on my six is that what they say I
don't know any nautical terms port he's
on my port side oh that's bad it's the
yellow guy in enemy I'm gonna say is
boom here we go now I found my distance
guys I found my distance so basically
the the weapons have a bit of a
cool-down period so you got a bob and
weave
you know like Muhammad Ali said look
like a beep sting like a butterfly right
or the other way around
I don't really know I'm not good with
quotes shoot it dude all right there we
go I feel like any time you're in a red
circle in a game that's bad now I'm on
fire is that mean like a good thing like
man I'm doing well shooting people
probably not
fire dude fire all right I seem to be
doing better here we go
ah hey it's that dude Oh caring have we
met before
where did we meet that's right
oh boy oh how many butterflies have
stung me I don't know but I did get bit
by a swan one time so guess what guys
Beauty can be dangerous
oh whoops ah I was what's that yes I
will tell you the story since no one
asked I was eight
oh there we go that's battle Bay baby
and I also like to drive through the
corpses of my enemies just to taunt them
oh dang it
what's what's happening hey hey
everybody
Conan O'Brien there we go look at this
all right look we're playing we're
playing out of the best game to make
it's rude not to make eye contact I'm
sorry because it's rude I don't care if
you're in the middle of a battle with
someone when another adult enters the
room okay and your gaming you make icon
okay
resume your game okay thank you we're
playing airplane battle Bay we're going
through ah some of the best games of
2017 on the Google Play Store you've
never played a mobile game have you what
again like on your mobile device like
and of course I have I played a mobile
game upwards yeah oh sure okay
of course I have yes all right well so
stupid I love mobile games yeah they
keep me from you know accepting the life
in the reality around me that's the best
thing about a mobile game there we go
all right you want to play battle Bay
yes okay all right so your love battle
Bey battle based awesome so here's how
you play so uh all right so basically
who wouldn't want to play battle I don't
know it's amazing all right let's say hi
to the chat there's a paycheque pillow
pants shush Obi Hey
Osama shahe czar and he mutts a wild
Conan Cronin roast me say hi Patrick hi
Patrick
let contemplate dumbass okay okay so
right I just uh yeah yeah who's Amish
the source says let call none all right
you want to play there's this game I
love called flippin legend I think I
have a long-lost son out there yeah yeah
call me we got to catch up man all right
you want to play uh there's a gate all
right now let's place a battle bed yeah
so basically this game uh you're a ship
you know Ashley let's get out of here
let's play a different game this is one
of my favorite games okay this game is
called flipping legend yes all right
flipping legend so what I love about
flipping legend is it's very simple
which will be great for this dude and
you're an archer okay right and I and
you're a very acrobatic art yes okay and
so yeah here we go all right so all you
need to do is you just tap either the
left or the right side and you're gonna
jump back and forth and you want to
avoid the bad guys
so you'll see but jump back and forth
and I mean you want to kill the bad guys
so you guys keep jumping how do I shoot
an arrow from an archer you know so go
you wanna hit that guy you want okay you
don't want to hit the pit all right wait
wait what do i when do I shoot well you
can hit it you can hit this thing to
shoot an arrow but you'll jump back it's
kind of a okay what happened died you
died well I don't understand person so
hey listen yes I know you're all gonna
be snorky about my skills with a Z but
it wasn't clear to me you just handed me
this thing occurred to me how I play
okay so basically there's a time limit
and it's it's counting down and so you
need to kill guys to keep getting wet
how do you kill them you you jump on you
just jump on them but you said I'm an
archer yeah but that's not how an archer
would function in the world he doesn't
jump he shoots an arrow but he's like an
at ease like an acrobatic arteries like
a ninja or Plagueis never shooters era
well so you have once in awhile you can
shoot an arrow
what is he you can only jump diagonal
you know chess yeah okay it's not but
what does that have to do with art you
know I'm just saying like in chess you
know there don't call this an archer
game that's stupid
what are you okay it's like chai is this
an archer key so not an archer game no
all right so call it Archer but call it
hop on crush hop on crush let's try
all right hop on crunch all right so you
can only go diagonally so you want to
tap left and right right right so to
keep going and your time is running out
there at the top see so you want to jump
on those guys but sometimes so sometimes
it's not gonna line up oh there you go
see you hit your arrow thing you don't
want to jump into the pit you got to go
fast you gotta go fast like pow pow pow
there you go
pow pow yep there you see this dump what
you doing out your hands well I'm okay
I'm just trying to get you this there
you go oh yeah look at this yes let's
see how I'm supposed to go this speed
yeah well you can get this is the way
you play chess chess is a great analogy
I just put no thought into it you just
mash around this game certainly this
game this game would not have passed
muster in 1979 I'm just saying that it's
a you know like that you can only move
certain ways there you go see you're
killing all the dudes yeah you're doing
really good man you're like doing well
you don't say good are you doing let's
use proper grammar you're doing us
awesome is that can you say awesome yeah
you say awesome all the time awesome so
you're not a real adult have you had a
net do you have you had an adult
relationship in your life no I mean not
with a person or like a video game
whatever all right no not with a person
with a video game like I you know
there's you walk around the office
wearing ironic watches and saying
awesome sauce that's true I got a watch
on today it has a dot in the law that's
great his watch in doesn't even tell
time it's just that because he's such a
hipster yeah but who needs to know what
time it is right that's true yeah well
you know I'm just saying you know time
is a construct anyway right it's not all
just time isn't real same room with you
you don't have to yet okay I'm just all
right are you want to play oh and
watching I apologize me play he yells
way too much he thinks everything's
awesome everything is great yeah
yesterday some mustard spilled on the
floor knee pointed out and said isn't
that awesome all right wait speaking of
mustard speaking of mustard how about a
cooking game yes a game where you cook
things this game is called cooking craze
it's one of the best to pick up and play
yeah if you don't like cooking yeah I
don't like cooking what better way to
spend your free time than playing a game
where you simulate the thing you don't
like to do
have you ever what you do what's your uh
I make one thing all right what do you
make I make a tuna fish sandwich
with chopped onion and mayonnaise and I
put it on toast gross I also can make
new ramen noodles so I can make those
two things and I like to have them
together oh I like those two things
ramen noodles a bowl of ramen noodles
and a tuna fish sandwich with some onion
in it those are the only things that I
made all the time that I was a writer
sir Night Live Simpsons
all the shows I've worked on when all
those years that I was alone working on
my craft yeah I call it a craft that's
how I worked on that that's what fueled
you that was your creative fuel in those
years those eighteen years if you're
calling in if you wonder why I'm dressed
like a 1930s newsman I don't know we
have a lot of work today and I was
really busy so I came right from a
workout because you don't just get this
body and I wore my kooky hat and whose
what why the ladies are laughing at my
body remark Pansear is asking to
pregnant you pregnant pregnant them on
and pregnant me I don't know if that
pregnant out of verb is Coenen a real
comedian no really
not really I love it though the you're
asking me I say you seem genuinely
confused no I'm not a real comedian
those are you know what's been bad when
people can make hot pockets we have you
have you had a hot pocket what's your
position on hot pockets movie my
position there addition that's an
efficient way to to eat something bad
quickly all right do you want do you
want to uh do you want to do a quick
cooking game quickly before you go I
know you have a show to do they're very
very quick yeah let's do the cooking
game all right we're gonna do all right
we're gonna do this is gonna make donuts
are you donut fan and I love donuts I
try not to eat them sure because it's
all sugar and carbs yes nothing in there
and every time you eat a doughnut you
shorten your life this is a true fact by
one year that's been proven if you have
like eight doughnuts you're gonna be
dead in at least a year if you're in
your 40s all right so let's make some
donuts here we go so here we go we're
trying to please that's a stereotypical
view of us yeah I don't think it's he's
clearly Italian you're making a pizza
pie look at them so what am i doing all
right so there's gonna be cost
they're gonna come up and they're gonna
have what they want that's not what
they're asking for is like a sprinkle
chocolate doughnut it's our job to cook
the doughnuts and keep the kid on okay
okay keep the kitchen weak so you want
to tap the doughnuts keep tapping the
doughnuts and then when they're done
they're to put them over just half the
doughnut they're done they're burning
tap the doughnut - yup put it over there
all right now I got to put some
chocolate sauce on there you'll hit some
coconut sprinkles for that guy coconut
sprinkles for that guy you could just
tap the coconut tap the coconut
sprinkles yeah all right now give that
guy that doughnut press the Pressley
which guy he doesn't want that just have
to don't it'll go to the right guy oh it
automatically goes to the right guy what
skill as that but you got to keep
tapping the doughnuts to keep them keep
the kitchen movie okay okay yeah keep
okay yep doughnut pee tap the pink
doughnut there I got it all right yeah
give the guy the milkshake there all
right your doughnuts are burnin all
right give that now you want to put the
pink sauce on the other doughnut by up
this guy is doing way kind of trying to
find you doves are full so you got to do
the pink sauce and the doughnuts there
you go yes yes there we go there we go
all right now that you know chocolate
can I say something yes there's not
enough people working here he's got a
kind of business look at this jerk burn
something burn something he knows I
burned something he knows I burned
something take over all right see that
Oh see you tap it twice to toss it away
see look look at that look at this so
you like game there we go see you just
got it's all about donut management you
know you just gotta gotta keep it go and
keep they keep the kitchen move in there
we go it's gay no shake one of maybe six
reasons why the American Empire is in
decline that's right there we got the
coconut sprinkles look at this you see
it's just like it's all about tapping
it's all about you just got to keep that
baby going I think I could probably run
a donut shop right there's an L for
giving the donut at the elf
3 dish combo look at that you're there's
an empty person inside there's nothing
inside you that's an empty shell this is
true uh
all right you know it's not a good game
when I'm actually being distracted by a
bottle of water it's sitting on the
floor I saw this and I was looking at it
like huh that bottle doesn't have
I wonder what kind of bottled water it
is it looks like it hasn't had no one
had it yet but seems to be room
temperature that's what I'm thinking
about while you make it I'm killing it
over here look at this thing snowman guy
got this stuff this is for children yeah
yeah I mean yeah it's with there we go
I'm a winner look at that no yes it just
said I'm a winner you're just your life
was just affirmed that's by an offensive
stereotype that's right exactly
I'm a winner I thank you by the way for
the jacket the the Christmas gift that
we all got thank you for that jacket did
you pick that pick that I did actually
save me a bunch of options for the
Christmas jacket and I saw that bomber
with a hood yeah and I liked it yeah I
said there's only one problem
it doesn't say Conan and when people
walk around with and that's the kind of
a hole I am when I give a gift it has my
name stamp when I give my you know my
mother us a bouquet of flowers it spells
out watch Conan on TBS
yeah see there it is right there that's
a nice bomber jacket right there you
can't really see you'd have to have
someone model it yeah the best model did
earlier there okay I've got it got it
cool a zip around the bicep there just
got these cool pockets yeah you can keep
all your cool stuff that's right it's
pretty great um how long have you been
doing honey games you playing uh we're
played all these games okay it's amazing
yeah we're in it's amazing what does
that mean it's amazing that there's this
many awesome games on the Google Play
Store everybody gonna notice me I have
Tito's tattoos for Heisenberg do you
want to see you want to see one other
game no okay all right all right well
thank you Happy Happy Holidays to the
check us happy holidays everybody
why do you talk to me like I'm an old
man a nursing home well you're wearing
that hat that looks like an old man
happy holidays are you gonna say it
grandma
get you mush mush hey someone said they
don't like my hat you crazy
look at all the stick I can do with this
hat hello golf net I'm sorry
[Laughter]
I'll Drive you
Bronx I've got a cab it's 1948 look at
this guy this guy ever even know that
guy does the hip hop kind of it was not
hip hop okay I don't know where you were
going
again this I'll see you guys later bye
everybody who's doing this and thank you
for your mostly calm positive comments
and you know occasional shitty ones all
right Thank You Conan thanks to the
jacket all right well look all I'm
saying is I think I'm glad Conan is a
runs a show and not a doughnut shop I
think we all we all know how how tragic
that was that's right I was happy by the
way I think that was Conan's holiday
gift to me this year he didn't punch me
do you notice that it's awesome that was
very that was probably the best part
yeah I mean although earlier in the
hallway he did offer me a CD from the
free bin which is a bunch of free stuff
we have in our office and then he hit it
out of my hands and I picked up and then
he kicked me in the back um sorry I'm
safe now bartylla go mad he'll not be
punching me anymore yes hopefully not
although you know what you never know
with that guy you got to you got to stay
on your guard at all times
even if he gives you a jacket you got to
look at the other hand see if it curls
do it fist if you're just joining us you
just miss Conan so sorry about that but
you can watch this on VOD later we are
running down some of my favorite games
on the Google Play Store so the best
games of 2017 is picked by the Google
Play editorial staff and me because I
like video games so we just so far we
played cooking craze we played balls
which is great a little battle but
paddle Bay which is fantastic and now
we're gonna play a game we did play a
little flipping legend which by the way
I think we should play again because I
love flipping legend and Conan did not
do it justice and this is again one one
of the reasons why I love mobile games
are you know this is flipping legend is
in the category of best indie game
and I will say as a rule I think indie
games a lot of times have the best music
and flipping legend I would listen to
this if this was on Spotify or Google
music I would listen to this this
soundtrack it's amazing so we're gonna
play flippin legend I want you all to
pay attention to when we get into the
graveyard how awesome this music gets so
let's go ready I did Abraham Van says
Aaron you just seem like a punchable
likable guy possibly more impossible
than likable tell Conan to stop wearing
hats to cover up that glorious wig so
basically the idea here is you're an
archer jumps around but you can you
basically jump around but you you do
have an arrow that you can change it's
all about the diagonals in this game so
you're trying to you have a time limit
but you gotta plan your moves out man to
get stuff and that's why I was trying to
say that it's kind of about chess is
it's kind of a strategy game if you
think about it in a certain way so you
kind of have to think on kind of a
couple levels you have to avoid things
but also think about where you want to
end up so you gotta you know it's like
forty chess man you got him oh hi that
was mine
here we go ready great music yes Beth
how good is this music oh I just died
though damn Oh Madelyn Sims this game is
super super fun all right here we go now
I haven't played this game a lot so I
have a portal that I can just go right
to the cool music because that's what we
want to see yeah now this if you hit the
graves oh that was dumb the other grants
a ghost will come out oh man a ghost
will come out and kind of follow you for
a couple moves so you got it you
actually have to camp it up and move
even faster here we go
let's go
I like any game that demands a high body
count there comes the ghost
they're the ghosts
look at this flipping legend man I want
to try to unlock oh there we go can't
catch me I'd love to unlock another
character during this stream shoot I
messed that up
dang it
there we go all right now into the cave
now we're like back in time like
Neanderthal times or something you got
to be careful the lava situation here
there's a lot there's a lot going on
damn I got to get to the point where I
can get a portal to place the Turia's
death counts yeah I don't know what how
many times have I died O'Malley how many
times you say I've died here I'm gonna
say that's for seven what I'm not no I
shouldn't I shouldn't get oh look at
this oh we could start at the cave dude
all right all right we're going with
seven even though I disagree I've only
made it through the cave one time in my
whole life damn it it's enough this is
another game it's super addictive
bartylla
next clueless gamer great question I'm
working on a couple at the moment good
how good is this music yes oh oh man
it's tough to lava man lavas like the
next so what is that 9 that's 8 8 or 9
all right let's go here we go ah next
close camera what do you guys want to
see I should have asked this mikonam is
in the room what would you like to uh
what would you like to see us play for
clueless gamer I've been playing uh what
do we been playing you know I went to
the video game awards which is super fun
Conan did a fun video for it which was
great and
shoot and something really cool is I
love one of the my favorite games this
year I got to meet the creator which was
super cool and I gotta say it's really
weird like you know it's fun meeting
like actors and actresses but when you
get to meet somebody in a video game who
you've been playing like it's super
weird cuz you were like emotionally
involved with that person like you were
playing them so it's like it's a whole
different world when you meet these
video game folks look at this now we're
talking Oh what's our official death
come I can't look up cuz I'm killing
pavement what is it
9 oh geez alright I just want to make it
past me just look at me just reckon
these cavemen that'll teach him to throw
big rocks oh wait cavemen clean up your
cave dude like how much lot like how
much lava I'd like to see like extreme
cave makeover you know oh here we go
now see I think I just kind of messed
myself up here here we go I've never
made it this far you guys what are these
things I'm fighting now are they like
lizard people they look like lizard
people
[Music]
oh man we got some quicksand going on oh
no no I'm about to die
oh my god you guys this is come out of
such a roll
flipping legend baby shoot this is no
joke really tough and I feel like but I
feel like I'm getting like super smart
or better at something oh man oh that
was awesome what a great run what are we
up to 10,000 a show Conan the deaf
stranding trailer yes I love it sure oh
my god woo new high score okay I'm it I
could play this game for the rest of
stream because I legitimate ly love this
game I'm gonna give it one more shot
because since we can start with a cave
that's a great upgrade I'm getting I'm
very otter says I'm getting better at
something dies immediately all right
here we go I will say I do wish the
deaths kind of carried over you can't
say like I'm in the zone man we get into
the zone and flippin legend you're a bad
bad man or woman bad person great person
[Music]
I love the thing one of the thing that I
one of the things that I think is so
cool with mobile games is you know with
huge video game titles it's kind of it's
the same thing as like oh man hold on
you get you can get some really great
ideas because it's not gonna cost a
gajillion dollars to make like this game
is as fun or more fun than any game I've
ever played
I'm definitely getting worked oh that
hurt me
I'm definitely getting as worked up
about it but again like this game
wouldn't be nearly as fun on a console
Oh No come on dude I guess your shield
doesn't help you if you fall down a hole
who did I defeated 25 cave people I
think how it was uh politically correct
cave people
that was dumb that was it that was a
dumb mistake
alright here we go gotta think a couple
moves ahead you know F that alright one
more time I'm sorry alright alright I'm
sorry we're not gonna play this game for
the rest of time but it's super
addictive I'm telling you man part of
the game don't you think the music is
part of this Beth yeah the music is just
like it's also there's a cut you get
into like a really cool rhythm which is
really fun
like when you knock a bunch of dudes out
in a row it's super satisfying man oh
man just barely Sammy
and also it's rant on fair also it's
random every time which makes it great
so it's like oh my gosh add a hundred to
the death counts as Jalen alright this
is the last time I'm playing this last
time playing this in the stream
it's guys it's just the mute the music
is so creepy and awesome this game
forever
and by the way I basically haven't
played this game forever I will say
there are cool parts of my job and one
of them is getting to play mobile games
for quote-unquote research look at me
wrecking these guys ooh
scourge of the cave people that's what
they call me on the streets they
actually don't call me that the streets
whoops
alright one more time this is the last
time I swear to you I'm really sorry
dislike these games man it's just like a
little window and this is a window into
my personal life
yeah this is why all right here we go oh
look at this
Oh bad also uh may I recommend if you
don't want to talk to your family for
the holidays mobile games are great if
you don't have a gift a last minute gift
Google oh god alright
Beth can I play one more time please is
that okay
alright sorry jeez I've never I've never
seen her pity me more alright here we go
alright sorry I just want to get I want
to get to the lizard people one more
time alright I feel like I deserve it
I've worked very hard at this
just got us I gotta see those I know
hold on just I know this is guys it was
really hard to narrow down my favorite
mobile games and you can see why because
all right hold on sorry oh no I gotta
get to the lizard people I'm sorry just
let me have this me not another play
it's a liar you guys all new eyes a liar
guys lizard people then we're going on
to the next game okay I'm really sorry
Beth you should you should have said no
you have to stop him
also the fact there's a time limit makes
things so dramatic oh that was dumb I
gotta be smart I might I might have to
not talk here for a second how good am I
though at this game Beth pretty good
gotta wait Oh Beth is an enabler she is
actually next game okay fine whoops
all right neck we're gonna play the next
game here one second oh you know what
okay look I can't go forward because I
don't have enough gold okay so that you
know what that's a cosmic sign I need to
relax on flipping legend all right so
that game is flipping legend it's super
fun okay so now it's gonna be game you
like Harry Potter yeah we all do you
like making potions yeah we all do
I gotta get a saved game found I do
think we want to continue this game's
called miracle merchants it's also in
the best indie category in the Google
Play Store and this game is so I love
the animation in this game so yeah so
let's get going so basically it's a card
game and you're it's basically kind of a
half puzzler half card game so these
cards down below what we're trying to do
is when somebody comes in like this poor
fool look at how sweaty this guy is by
the way you know maybe you shouldn't
carry like rock like 15 rocks on your
belt and then you wouldn't be so sweaty
we see Karen like a cello back there a
bassoon anyway you want to make so
basically what he has in the the circle
word bubble is what you must make a
potion
so he we have to do a blue card all
right and then what he wants what he
loves is in the love bubble which is
also the name of my apartment the love
bubble sorry Beth that he wants a green
card so to make him happy
well we'll also put in a green card and
what we want to do is there's a point
total on each card and there's also how
much you have to get to see that little
dollar bill you want that to be above
one or you lose so the other thing about
these there's like at the bottom of the
card you see how on the green one
there's a little clover and the blue one
there's a little blue pimple or bump or
boil Gorder there's a little blue goiter
there on the bottom the blue card that
means you'll get extra points if you put
a blue card to the left so let's do that
also black cards are the worst and I
hate them and they're nice to get out of
the way so I'm just gonna do this and
get it out of the way it's two we got a
bonus he's happy we made a minor blue
twin potion I wouldn't drink out of that
Cup though it kinda looks disgusting
alright so this this lady just wants
first of all she looks like a very angry
this these are the looks I get whenever
I go to Trader Joe's from other shoppers
because I wander around and I don't have
a list so this is a woman looking at me
like every single mom at Trader Joe's so
she wants a green let's get her a green
to her [ __ ] ways that's right
so yeah there's a bunch of really good
card games and that's something to is
like that's one of the great things
about mobile games as well is these card
games are super fun and there's a
million different variations on them but
I like this one American merchant
because it's kind of magic based I
really love the the animation style as
well as very cool alright so we got a
blue border at the bottom we don't have
any blue cards so we can't do that
she wants a red thing okay now the
diamond at the bottom means we could put
a yellow there and she'll be happy we're
at four so let's put in them let's put
in a dart card and get rid of it right
she's giving me a bad look anyway so
screw weak potion to the void you know
what if you were nicer to me maybe I
give you a better potion all right here
we go
also you know what guys it's the holiday
season
be nice to customer service people this
is just a PSA from all of us at Team
Coco you know everybody's working hard
we're all trying to get stuff out and
we're all trying to do our job just be
nice you know like this guy he's clearly
a monster but he's smiling at me he's
being a pleasant guy so that makes me
want to help him more if someone's mean
to me I don't want to help them you know
so just a little PSA from your pal your
old pal bleh all right here we go we got
a green one all right I think I like to
get rid of the black cards as soon as
possible oh wait but we have to wait so
let's do a red red one here and then a
blue one and there we go we hope to look
at that ten
there we go that's we're talking about
carrying tomorrow beam evil merchant we
miss Schade fridge
we're in hey shady fridge we interrupt
this gameplay for blaze PSA I got a lot
of PSAs all right now this guy hopefully
is hoping for some kind of skin cream
because that looks like eczema gone out
of control or maybe tried to shave his
arms he has terrible razor burn whatever
it is all right now this guy actually
wants a black card which is gonna be
fantastic but that means we have to get
high enough I think in our count I don't
know if this is gonna happen I'm gonna
oh man I should have booted him all
right maybe it will all right we got a
blue one there it's giving it let's give
it it oh man this is gonna be tough all
right let's give it a - we're down to
one man this is a yeah I think this is
gonna be can I take this I can't take it
out can I all right that's fine all
right let's see what happens I didn't
want to fail ah yes all right good all
right you also get bonuses I forget I
will say in trying to research
10,000,000 games I will say I've
forgotten some of the rules of some of
these games if you get two of the same
color card you get a twin bonus which is
great his emotes to be especially bad
it looks like the zombie merchant from
Resident Evil 4 he's got some dope
friends yeah alright here we go now she
looks like some kind of a superhero and
she wants a red card so let's hook it up
she would also love a yellow one
although I don't know if we're gonna be
able to get it to her
maybe we can well let's do this here we
go can I put this over here please
there we go all right there we go
yo man that's just a little merit I'm
just miracle americlean merchant inning
in it up that's all I do is miracle II
merchant it that's how you say it right
alright let's do one more guy this dude
looks awesome by the way
alright this guy's going to a sweet rave
this is very lady gaga esque he's got
going on by the way that's a great great
documentary if you haven't seen her
documentary 5 foot 2 it's fantastic here
we go we got a black card on the that
side how is this gonna work um okay you
know what he wants a green one all right
let's scoot this in there and then how
are we gonna do this is gonna be tough
alright I also we're out of cards I
didn't even know that was possible now
I'm kind of worried all right well let's
just throw one in there he loves yellow
right let's get that twin bonus boom all
right
hey snackmaster ass are you scared Conan
is gonna burst in with a camera crew no
because the camera crew are those guys
are my pals because we go on all those
travel shows together so those guys
would give me the heads up they wouldn't
you know they wouldn't give me the Rudy
do they wouldn't give me the old
razzamatazz those guy I would get a text
saying like hey bleh
we about to come in and blow up your
spot alright here we go
how is this gonna work man this is tough
dude we got the twin bonus Oh he wants a
red one I guess we could do this right
boom nailed it alright twinsies normal
yellow twin potion coming right up and
it came with a specialist Culpeper a
Culpeper sorry not a skull pepper
saying this game alright I'm gonna help
this alien guy out and then I'm gonna
help the yellow guy out cuz he's looking
really scared and I just want to make
sure he's having a good holiday
okay I gotta gotta skip that dude back
to the line pal oh no I gotta skip this
guy too
oh no I don't here we go you do this we
do one of these we can get a yellowy
going on there oh um and I guess another
red for a twin bonus check it out oh my
god the side of that guy's head is
opening up oh that's his mouth whoops
sorry about that oh look at this dude
this guy needs to watch his clothes
there are those bedbugs
that's horrible um well I'm gonna quit
out of this game because it's looking
pretty dire for me right now so uh let's
move on to the next semes shall we again
miracle merchant is the best and E
category pretty awesome okay now we're
gonna play a game that's near and dear
to my heart
it's holiday hair now here's the thing
there are also games on the Google Play
Store for children and this is the one
and this is one for the best for kids
category but you know what kids games
can also be played by adults so can you
go - uh
here we go oh whoops what happened there
I'm not sure what happened but yes so Oh
son of a kids games also can be enjoyed
by adults here we go
that's right
all right here we go we're gonna travel
now the whole point of holiday here is
you're traveling the world and you want
to match the hairstyle of the city
you're in - your hair now look I know
that sounds like a ridiculous premise
but I will say different towns have
different hair styles you know I went to
New York and everybody's got a high and
tight or whatever you come out to LA
everyone's got the windblown very wind
blood very Santa Ana wind blown hair all
right so let's see we got here I wasn't
paying attention to what she was saying
okay here we go
blue dreams I don't know how I feel
about this one all right
let's let's take the lead with the new
styles shall we okay what do I do here
let's brush our hair let's do get that
get that hair brush going out there you
know I'm a stylist if I'm having a bad
day I feel like there's no way you can
be sad and play this game so if you're
feeling down I highly recommend the
Strawberry Shortcake look at this she's
just like surprised she's like oh my
gosh I'm gonna make her kana let's do
well well well why thank you um I'm not
sure what I'm supposed to do here let's
let's look at what we're doing let's go
to Cairo shall we
[Music]
oh boy a lot of sand ladies this is a
bat that this is like a dangerous level
for good hair you know so let's uh I'm
ready let's do it all right yeah I agree
okay I'm gonna do blue what do you think
that blow-dryer no we probably want like
what is this like a shower what is this
I don't really
oh yeah it's a shower oh you know what
this is this is probably a bad idea now
it's just gonna be mud this is I already
have a gold from the hair Olympics you
just already gave me one but this is a
terrible idea cuz all we're doing is
making mud in this girl's hair this is
terrible
alright hold on let me just finish here
real quick all right what gift do we are
oh yeah we got an Egypt sticker the
voices are amazing Weezy Mac right oh
you said annoying see I said amazing
whoo baby
not bad Oh God all right all right
enough of the holiday hair we've done it
I'm not good with hair obviously because
I've been cursed with this hair since I
was 14
alright so here we go so now we're gonna
play a little game it was actually uh
here we go a little game called bubble
witch 3 now this game I'm gonna spare
you the cutscene but in the this game
has an amazing premise and in this game
dragons are attacking the world okay and
you're a bubble witch and we were
supposed to do is defend the earth from
dragons with the help of your cat by
unlocking by shooting bubbles and
unlocking owls from bubbles I don't know
how somebody came up with this idea but
I look who felt Nero's orb okay it is
all right we gotta fill this get dudes
or I'm not sure how to do that oh I see
all the bubbles just go in his orb
I don't trust a talking cat
I never havin never will Puss in Boots I
don't care if he's voiced by Antonio
Banderas I don't trust him all right by
the way this is a pretty hip which so oh
this is like a bomb bubble how come you
hold on one second I gotta make sure I'm
gonna get boom yeah sweet bomb bubble
I'm an example of what not to be says
sewing Tomcat uh I would I would agree
with that
haven't you at that statement um you
know I play video games for a living I'm
not adding a lot to society I think here
we go one second I do love though I will
say how video games have become one of
the biggest forms of entertainment the
world and I think that's because you
know when you're playing a game like I
am the bubble which you know what I'm
saying or the bubble which three maybe
this isn't a sequel maybe her name is
just bubble which three and she has two
older sisters but I'm Way more
emotionally involved because I am doing
something in the game so like even a
game like balls or as you guys saw when
I lost my mind a little bit with
flipping legends it's a way more video
games especially mobile games are a way
more visceral experience because
especially the mobile game you're so
much closer to the action like look at
you're leaning forward you're not just
like sitting back watching TV you're in
it man
I gotta save the earth from these gosh
darn dragons and how are we gonna do it
we're gonna fill Nero Nero's sack full
of bubbles hold on and legitimately is
it is hard to do this in Tuck who busy
bakes says I used to drink to drugs at
Steel that I started watching you play
video games it said thank you you're
welcome busy big
and happy holidays once again if you
guys are just joining us we partner with
Google Play we're playing for the first
time ever
but some mobile games kkona MS in here
I'm making fun of me he didn't punch me
though which I'm very excited about and
yeah if you or give the gift of mobile
games this holiday season there we go
I'm the dolphin 4head I don't know what
that means uh that's right knock on wood
yes do you think I have a dolphin 4head
bath kind of I think it's this you know
what I think part of it is I think I'm
kind of dressed in a dolphin color
palette you know like this is like a
dolphin white I'm in the sea I live in
water exactly what was my first game
savate gasps ah that's a great question
I don't know I think it was oh man I
couldn't tell you that game a life guys
you know playing this game called life
Conan does do great habits he's always
he's got a great hat he's got great hat
bits habits 24/7 in the office that's
right it's kind of weird seeing me play
games I have no idea yeah I will say but
that's the cool thing too is like mobile
games are super easy to pick up and play
which is awesome oh my god Carolina's
Facebook is on a level 375 of bubble
which three dude wait can you ask her
then like what happened do we save the
do we save the earth from dragons maybe
I'm gonna say no one actually another
thing I'm actually was actually super
surprised about and I love and the fact
that they're like cutscenes in mobile
games like they're legitimate crazy
games they give like consoles or run for
their money it's awesome level six baby
look at it yes the wink I love it
alright we're gonna switch here to what
was voted the best game of the year or
picked is the best game of the year is a
little game called cats all right now
look Internet the internet loves cats
but this is C 80s and I don't know what
it stands for but we're gonna learn that
in a second and it
basically you like Robo Wars or that
what's that TV show BattleBots
this is kind of bad about to crash arena
turbo stars it's cats internet loves
everybody loves cats and it's cats
fighting each other in robots and in
giant battle things alright so let's
switch to this as we can here we go
and even better I don't need it's not
gonna be on me if I lose so here we go
I'm on the left I've got my rocket
launcher look at me just owning this guy
Yammer whoo get that win streak to five
cats baby I love cats is amorphous now
playing yes it's awesome Animal Crossing
for yeah baby for mobile clueless gamer
you never know
alright here we go two quick fight I got
a good I will say I didn't realize in
choosing the shape of my car what a
great boon it was that it's kind of a
wedge shape because again I'm scrappy I
haven't leveled up that much and so one
of the ways I'm gonna win is by pushing
this guy up and shooting at the soft
underbelly of his car ready oh man
Oh woah he blew up what happened there
he like blew up behind me oh my god this
is great shove him another thing yes
yeah I'll take a win is a win baby win
streak six I am as good at this game as
I am bad at flipping legend here we go
nope don't want to edit let's go
cat eye cat violence is no joking matter
it is who said I'm talking about oh but
now he's kind of shooting me ah take
that out lean Davitt also you're playing
against real people which is always like
kind of harrowing like when you're
playing it's real people for some reason
like it gets my blood up more reverend
nine hundred before christmas time is
going very well i'm kicking the bejesus
out of these other cats now this dude
has a lot of stickers I've never seen
this weapon before what is that like a
laser or is that just like a giant
speaker do you see that
looks like a speaker oh it pushed me oh
no this is bad
yes dude see all I've been doing is like
amping up my rocket launcher and I think
it's been working yeah baby all right
here we go let's even get to 10
there we go ready fall fee oh this looks
bad I'm gonna say right now that buzzsaw
thing I've fought this thing before and
it I don't know if it's gonna I might
get destroyed here the bus I think sucks
oh my god whoa look at this that wasn't
offset all right true true facts captain
Jay Bristol me kicking the bejesus out
of these cats taking out of context when
I'm not playing cat the game cats might
sound a little bit troy horn or we do do
a daily gaming hour we don't but we do
do stream cocoa every week see that
thing is guys I'm murdering right now I
kind of don't want to stop because I
feel like I'm very superstitious and if
I stop I'm not gonna um that's right ah
fine to life 2016 Erin what do you think
about the new Spielberg movie about
video games oh man ready player one is
an amazing book I'm super excited about
it I've been trying to not watch
trailers what is that thing a scoop oh
oh that was a close one but trying to
not watch trailers cuz they just have my
money I'm gonna go see it but I think
it's great like I love that video games
are big in the culture finally you know
it they finally got some legitimacy and
now again like everybody has a phone in
their pocket and you can play game
anywhere you don't have to just be like
at home on a TV you can literally play
this game anywhere this dude doesn't
have any oh wow
I can't believe I lost to a car that had
no wheels that doesn't seem right that
doesn't seem fair
alright so guys before we go so we've
been playing a bunch of our favorite our
favorite games from the Google Play
Store I got to give a great shout out to
this game it's not fun to watch it
streamed but
I am obsessed with this game it's called
space plan and the idea what this game
is I wanted to give this game a special
shout out because you kind of all you do
is it's a counter that just goes up and
you just keep tapping a button and it
sounds incredibly simple and it is very
simple and it looks insane but it's
super super fun so this idea this is
actually I beat the game so I don't want
to show you the end but we're gonna
delete the game and restart so this game
you don't know what you're doing you
don't know where you are and so you kind
of tap can you actually move it down to
the left O'Malley via thing so there's a
whole story that goes along with this
space plan game and it's awesome it's
super super cool you don't know where
you are and on the right on the top
hello a wiki wiki let's get to work
where are we no idea systems are being
difficult power it's all messed up so
we're basically in a spaceship we don't
know where we are what's happening and
see this little flashing thing you hit
it to get watts you see I'm putting
together right here every time I hit
this thing I'm getting some extra watts
some wattage and I'm starting up my ship
alright so you got to hit this button a
bunch alright and now we could buy a
repair a solar panel right so now we're
gonna get point 1 watts per second so
we're putting this thing together now I
know this game seems ridiculous it is so
fun and there's a hole you just gotta
keep hitting this button there's a whole
world out there this game I played it
for two straight days it was the last
thing I thought about before I went to
sleep and the first thing I thought of
when I woke up so basically this is us
alright see that little dot right there
we're in orbit around this planet we
don't know what's happening and also no
look at this I could buy a potato
alright so I buy a potato there we go
now I've got 1 watt per second because
that we're using a potato for power see
this and we and I know this seems
ridiculous but Lee's going download this
game it's super fun we're a pair another
solar panel
there's a whole story that goes along
now we got see now we got we're slowly
building our wattage up as we go around
this planet but while we're in the Sun
those solar panels work see you see how
they're on the Left I know this is so
nervous right no no just wait hear me
out so now we're getting some wattage
here all right it's it's legitimately
crazy fun I know it sounds ridiculous
alright so now we're buying a couple
solar panels let me see I'm on the right
get us some more power please repair us
the idea Lister is up and running so
these are things we can buy so we can
clean our solar panels to give us more
energy bloody hell that obnoxious poot
of embarrassing software deads and it's
a really funny game so on the right this
game talks to you like the whole time
you're playing and it gets crazier and
crazier and crazier and the end of this
game there's like this cinematic this
8-bit cinematic which is makes it all
worth it so now we can clean our solar
panels clean them for three watts for
ten seconds there we go alright see we
amped up our power see we're getting a
little more powerful here you know now
this game I gotta say I started playing
this game and I went out to dinner and I
got so obsessed with this game and went
out to dinner is eating by myself I went
into this Mexican restaurant near my
house and because you get to a point
where pressing this button get like
super charges you a lot and you just
want to do it all the time so I came in
with my tablet to dinner I went and sat
down I eat dinner with one hand pressing
the tablet the whole time everyone
thought I was totally nuts but I did I
was punch of great stuff we go we're
gonna buy another potato see see we're
kind of getting our wattage up here you
see you know talking about you guys know
what I'm talking about even by myself
now I feel sad anyway so I kept playing
a complaints game and then I never
stopped hitting this button and then I
also then walked home and as I'm walking
home by the restaurant everyone was just
staring at me because I was just playing
this game the entire time it was awesome
so space plan I got to give it a shot up
it's super super fun but I'm not gonna
bore you by but it's not it's not a
great game to stream but it is super if
to play so all right so I think that's
gonna do it guys thank you for joining
us and my favorite game of the year as
I'm sure anyone who's watched the stream
for any amount of time for this last
hour is of course flippin legend I can't
stop playing flippin legend it's really
really fun the music is awesome it's
easy to play it's one it's one of the
classic games like easy to play
impossible to master so it's super fun
to get into a great rhythm but again
thank you to all the amazing developers
who make mobile games and continue to
make them thank you to Google Play for
partnering with us for this awesome
stream it's - yes I know lots of twitch
versus it seems hilarious but flippin
legend is absolutely incredible
so you guys got to play flippin legend
and I'm just gonna try to get this
soundtrack somewhere flippin legend
developers if you guys are watching
please email me your soundtrack so I can
just listen to it it's incredible we
will put up a list with all these games
for sure but this this hour we played
balls battle Bay miracle merchants
cooking craze flippin legend holiday
hair bubble witch 3 saga and the game of
the year is to turn by google play cats
but thank you guys for joining us check
out Google Play again amazing last
minute gift idea and keep mobile games a
shot man I am then converted I am a
mobile gamer it's unbelievable
god help us all thank you all for
joining us make sure to tune in tomorrow
at 1 p.m. Pacific for another stream
Coco I thank you to Kona for stopping by
happy holidays everybody see you guys
later marry otter captain Bristol Troy
Horner Marshall Zara Cates McCoy I will
see you guys later have a great day see
you later bud
you